It's not even about the like, I'm not saying that's 100% but like if you're not doing a contract, you're crazy. That's like why it's part of the process.
It's not that if they sign a six month contract, you're even going to take them to court like let's be real, the amount of money it's going to cost you to take them to court and how much you're going to get it's not really worth it.
The fact of the matter is when they know that there's a contract and they physically or or they intentionally sign it.
That is them committing. Okay. And I always use this analogy. Is it easier for someone to end a relationship that is like a boyfriend girlfriend relationship, or a marriage.
You might have like some real shit going on in your marriage but because you've committed because you've gone through that process you've signed that shit.
And because it's not as easy to get out of without having a little bit of like shit happen.
People think twice man people think twice three times four times sign that thing, even though you know damn well that like at the end of the day you're probably not going to get anything from them in court.
It's them signing it's them committing and here's how I pitch the contract gene. I say look yeah of course there's a contract. I'm committing to you I'm 100% exclusive to you. I can't talk to any other business owners.
So if we don't do an agreement, then that's like me being committed to you but you can quit at any time, right. I'm committing to you I'm not I'm ceasing all conversations with business owners.
I'm not calling on you that's like having a marriage where only one person's married the other person could do whatever the hell they want. Doesn't make sense. Yes, there's a contract it's six months at the end of six months if you don't like me I don't like you we end that shit.
Okay, but my guess is that at the end of this thing, you're just going to ask me if I can keep the price of the same and not increase the price because I'm going to be killing it for you. Okay, that's how I pitch it.
Don't shy away from it.